I know everyone's talking about Jerry as
a talk show host but he somebody
I knew
sorry I've just been on the phone been
crying with we shared a PA
I live around the corner from the
studios where we work from the NBC
family there's myself Jerry Springer
Maury Povich Steve Wilkos
it's like a family I mean he was so good
to me I knew him personally
you know I
when I was stressed once he gave me a
pink I've still got it my pink fluffy
nightgown and slippers how he was on TV
and how he was in real life or probably
there were some similarities but you
know he I I can't stress how much how
what a kind
person he was
to people around him
um I really can't stress that enough
because there there are a lot of Divas
in our business
uh and he certainly wasn't wasn't one of
them I remember when I first met him in
um New Orleans that in 1999 we knew we
were laughing because we knew wherever
he was because you could hear Jerry
Jerry and where's the joke because there
were these empty sort of these flatbed
pickup trucks with we used to call the
Billy Bob and Bobby bill you know with
with the one the overalls with one strap
and what have you and they he was
treated like an absolute God by his you
know his guests and his audience but
they they knew what they were getting
into when they appeared on on his show
um
and he could he could he was the master
of saying something without saying
anything he could just do it with a look
as well uh so yeah it's just
um one of a kind